Welcome to the Sam and Niko channel episode 200: Street Meat
Sync, we gotta sync!
There's a dude carrying a grill down our street wearing a robe
Hi!
Check this guy out
Are you gonna grill some food?
Yeah!
I know you guys don't like it when people stop by, I'm not asking for you to hang out with me
So I spent up til like three in the morning making some uh, some of my uh special bourbon splashed beef so
Would you guys be alright if I provided some of it?
Sure!
Let's find out
So you're just gonna.. grill?
Yeah man, seriously
I've been uh, working this recipe for the past week so..(pew pew pew noise)
Oh damn!
Yeah, I hope you like it
Spin Master hooked us up with some sweet air hogs drones
What we have here is the X-wing vs Death Star battle kit
How this works - the Death Star floats on its own and shoots infrared beams at your X-wing which you pilot
If this hits you three times this goes down
Thanks to Spin Master for sponsoring this, we're probably going to destroy.. half of these in the next hour
Easy!
Dude I got this, I got this, I got this, it's so easy
I'm sittin' here
Just guide me thr-
I got you. OK
They will take off and I will be timing them - they'll have three attempts on the Death Star to kill it
And once the Death Star crashes out of the sky, they have officially destroyed the Death Star
Judge it based on time, whether or not they have destroyed the Death Star, banter with their fellow co-pilots
And wisdom that they dispense about the force
Is one of the prizes (someone says dignity) dignity? Respect? Honour?
A real lightsaber
(echoes) a real lightsaber
(Wren gasps)
I want a real lightsaber
First up is Niko
This is you right here, my son
Right there?- Yeah
Sick son
Red two, standing by
Red eleven, standing by
Red five, standing by
Let me know when to start Ben
Easy!
Dude I got this, I got this, I got this, this is so easy
I can see the Death star getting red when I hit it
I did it! I did it!
Woo!
How long was that?
Fourteen point nine six seconds (0:14.96)
So, Niko had four attempts this round: His first one was a false start, his second one the Death Star crashed inadvertently
The third one - in fourteen point nine six seconds he destroyed the Death Star, which gives him a total of ten points
Oh
Hey Steve
Hey!
There's a guy out front, cooking
Tell him to move that shit outta there
That's what I was just gonna tell him
No, no seriously, he's actually put some barbeque briquettes on the grill
That's what I heard
Yeah..
I haven't been out there yet
Well, I asked him, I said "what's going on", he says "I'm cooking for Sam and Niko
Damn!
Hope you don't - hope you don't mind
That's weird, you know that?
a little bit
I can't stop you if my landlord tells you to leave
Is this uh, your recipe?
Asian themed, but instead of- I used some western ingredients, so hopefully it's good
Alright
Hungry Jake?
I guess so
Well I'll tell ya, ordinarily I would evict immediately any tenant who would ever - I'm serious! - barbecue
and have that - but!
Because it is Sam and Niko I automatically totally and fully approve of it
(laughs)
'Sup!
This guy's cool
I approve of him being out here cooking
It's illegal and I love it
The more things that are like that, the more this area stays real and not like those bunch of pussies that live a few blocks north
Up next is gonna be.. Wren
One, two!-
I shot it I shot it!
Shoot it
Shoot it, son
We got uh, we've got a rogue pilot here
It sounded like the X-wing just went down
Where'd it go?
Alright, you're out
Where'd it go- Mr Kenobi, no!
I was Darth Vader the whole time
So Wren's second time was uh one minute, seventeen seconds and seventy somethings - seventy hundredths of a second (1:17.70)
What would you- How would you describe that performance, you trained him
(Wren screams: Uncle Ben, he failed me!)
Um it was probably one of the worst things I've ever seen
Before we go any further I think we should all go out and check out the meat
I have some reservations about the street meat
I'm pretty excited son
Wait, what is going on with this meat - I heard you guys yelling about meat
Steve- Steve runs inside saying "if there's anyone else cooking meat.. but I love Sam and Niko
So a dude showed up, on our street - Who?
Does he live here? - No
He's a fan
He's openly acknowledged that he saw the video where we asked that people not come to the studio
But he said he would really like to cook for us
Wait, are you for real?
Yeah
Did he contact anyone?
No
He said it would be superfluous if he did so he didn't
Is this like- Is it SAFE to eat?
Or is it like, poisoned
That, you will have to find out for yourself
Ok,- who- did we draw first to see who tastes it first?
(Someone:) I'll try it first, I didn't bring a lunch
Come and get it boys!
Time to meet the chef
How's it going?
Need a little more time?
Do you need me to move? - No
That looks good
So basically it's asian based - some people don't really know this, one ingredient they never tell you to put in
Which you have to put in, Fish Sauce
Always, you gotta put in fish sauce - it has that level of saltiness and savouriness
Use whatever liquor you want - you can use bourbon, you can use whisky or you know you could use vodka
Makes me think like, this is kinda for real
Well why is Niko doing so much better if you've trained everyone here?
Take off your black shirt
Let's do this
We're gonna up the stakes
Flying in here- as exciting as it is, we're gonna up the stakes to really match the first- the fourth Star Wars movie
We're gonna run the gauntlet all the way down the hallway
You're gonna have to fly the drone without crashing it around to the loading dock
And THEN shoot down the Death Star
Sam you can't go in this door
You have to go the other way around
Dude. Good job
Fire the missile son
You see it?
Son, fire the missile son
Sam got shot down
Thanks man and apologies at the same time
Wow, thank you
Dude, you're fricking awesome
No, you guys are awesome, what you guys do? Seriously, saves lives
How's it look Niko?
Looks really good
First taste
You ready?
I'm ready
How is it? - It's so good!
(Carmichael: fake choking sounds)
'Sup.. guys
You know what, not gonna lie
I brought these
Dude, it's doing more
Imagine this, but in sweater form
They're on sale now in the Corridor Digital store - corridordigital.com/store
Limited time only